pokem man made a big mistake she tried
to sell a cookie I know I know it sounds
ridiculous and trust me it is but for
whatever reason people are losing their
goddamn Minds about this and every time
you think it's over someone else opens
their mouth so allow me to simplify
everything and explain why it's all
blown out of
control 3 weeks ago Pokey man teased on
Twitter that she would be launching a
new product 2 years in the making the
following week she announced Mina snacks
basically these little cookies that are
supposedly a healthier alternative to
other snacking options now a normal
response to seeing this would be just to
say okay but for whatever reason people
lost their goddamn Minds sure there were
some people that seemed excited about
this new delectable treat but of course
since this is pokey man there were a
bunch of Nays it started with people
investigating the actual product itself
there were claims that nearly identical
cookies were being sold at Costco for a
fraction of of the price which if true
Drop Shipping cookies would sort of poke
holes in her inspiring mission statement
to create the elevated snack but later
Poké man responded to these accusations
with some much needed context Poké man
clarified that the Costco dupes were in
fact made by the same manufacturer
Creator foods but those were already
discontinued and Poké man worked with
the manufacturer to improve the cookies
make them more healthy but keep the
flavor profile she goes on to say that
white labeling like this is extremely
common in this industry and when it
comes to the price pokm main says it's
Parton Parcel when making something
healthy and if she wanted a cash grab
she would have just done something else
now of course this was not good enough
for basically anyone and although she
once again saw some Defenders the
storm was getting worse even if some
people took her explanation at face
value many were still upset at the $7
price tag for a single bag of these
cookies claiming it was out of touch
especially in this economy that
culminated in pokem man getting
frustrated and saying this to a
perturbed chatter like oh my my God $28
for
cookies it's four
bags that's seven $7 a bag I know I know
math is
hard when you're an idiot
but like if you're a broke boy just say
so I'll admit probably not the best
response she could have had but those
two simple words broke boy absolutely
exploded the vast majority of responses
heavily criticize Poké man for what she
said and help solidify their opinions
that this entire Venture was out of
touch but things got so out of hand that
other creators started weighing in on
the situation I don't know what would
possess her to say something so rude and
nasty to the audience she is trying to
sell this product to to directly shame
the consumer that you want to buy into
your product is a Galaxy brain tactic a
strategy that I'm not sure the success
rate of critical went on to say that
when you boil it down the product is
just flat out too expensive and that
people are allowed to make these
criticisms if they want to and Pokémon
man should respect them because they are
the ones that are likely going to buy
the product in the first place and the
Really foul part about all of this that
my little noodle will never be able to
wrap itself around is a streamer calling
Their audience broke or
poor bub your wealth was built on their
backs them watching you supplied you
with money through the ads that get
played to them them directly donating to
you took their money and gave it to you
if they weren't watching you you would
be getting no sponsors which make up a
lot of streamers income you need them
and you are dropping trouser and
in their mouth right now by
just insulting them Poké man continued
to phas backlash from other content
creators and even some defense but one
Camp greatly outnumbered the other this
resulted in pokem man walking back what
she said as a simple joke but agreeing
that it came off as in sensitive and
that she would be working on the pricing
in the future now I bet that most people
thought that this would be over and done
with right here but of course we would
be greatly mistaken Poky man sent xqc
some of her cookies to try for free also
probably not a good idea on her part but
of course xqc tried them on stream and
said that they were quote not terrible
but not great either in a later stream
kaisan asked pokem man what her thoughts
on xqc's comments were to which she said
that x quote had a bone to pick with her
I think X might have a bone to pick so
he can say and do whatever he wants you
know it's all good what did I yo I seen
a clip of X bro what did I do man you
see that about your cookies for me it
was like almost relatable like oh I'm
like I'm making a joke people are
calling me out way too hard for this
right I was like oh it's kind of cool to
see somebody who's like normally more
respected do the same behavior right I I
got to make fun of them the same way
they make fun of me and it's it's almost
relatable you know I'm just a voice out
of all the voices I get the cookies
ahead of time I because she gave to me
and I'm very I'm thankful I give an
honest review about the product I give a
I give a a honest review I tried my best
chat to objectively say what I felt
about testing the cookie with no bias
and I a massive cookie snack fan now
that seems to be the end of this current
debacle but given that xqc and his
audience are now involved I highly doubt
it is which leads me to the ultimate
question why do people care about this
cookie yes people are entitled to their
own opinion on things like this and I
don't really feel bad when someone's
product gets criticized it happens all
the time but come on this just seems all
a bit ridiculous over a cookie in fact
this is all very reminiscent of the time
that valky re tried to release that
gamer skincare line and got absolutely
blasted online for it now the obvious
common through line with these stories
is that they are both prominent female
creators Nadia a woman who has also
dealt with her fair share of hate came
out and claimed that there was a double
standard for women in comparison to men
people like sneo who spread vitual
online all day plenty of people
disagreed with Nadia and at one point
there was even a community note
suggesting the male Creator she named
also faced equal backlash to which I
respond come on let's be real here there
is a major difference between the
content that Poké man makes versus what
sneo puts out now my opinion on the
actual product itself these cookies that
Poké Man released is the same that I
feel about every other product that
these creators release it's just more
junk we probably don't need but it's not
crazy to think that this entire
situation is just steeped in a massive
double standard listen I'm open to the
discussion but I just don't see a male
Creator getting a tenth of the hate what
I do know is that this was all over a
cookie and although Pok man's response
wasn't great I just hope to God we can
move on but I want to know what you all
think is it absolutely necessary to
respond whenever a Creator we don't like
releases something is there a clear
double standard going on and most
importantly would you eat the
cookie favorite cookies yeah we can talk
about them um the reverse decadent you
know the one that's like the it's
actually kind of similar to what this
cookie is but it's like just the PC
brand one Canadians know about the real
PC brand but pirate cookies I also
really like pirate cookies they're
oatmeal and peanut butter I'm a cookie
guy if you can't tell